IS WHAT YOUR SHOW, IN FAIRNESS,
IT IS.
>> Tucker: THANKS, I
APPRECIATE THAT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
NATIONALLY, DEMOCRATS CALL
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH THEIR
BEYOND THAT.
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
JAVIER BECERRA IS TURNING THEM
TO PROSECUTION IF THEY VIOLATE
HAS SPENT A LOT OF TIME THINKING
ABOUT THE QUESTION OF
IMMIGRATION.
OF YOU.
MR. ALLEN, DO YOU FIRST, ARE WE
OVERSTATING IT OR DOES IT SEEM
LIKE ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS WHERE
THE UNIT BEGINS TO FALL APART
WHEN YOU'RE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAYS HE WILL PROSECUTE
CALIFORNIANS FOR OBEYING FEDERAL
LAW?
THAT SEEMS A BIG DEAL TO ME.
>> THIS IS A VERY BIG DEAL.
THIS GOES FAR BEYOND LEGISLATORS
NOW YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL LITERALLY,
CRIMINALLY, CRIMINALLY TRYING TO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
HE IS INSTRUCTING CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS OWNERS THAT IF YOU TRY
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW, YOU WILL BE
PROSECUTED UNDER STATE LAW.
HE HAS CROSSED THE LINE.
AT THIS IS NOW A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NEEDS TO
COME, SESSIONS AND TRUMPET NEED
TO COME TO CALIFORNIA, LITERALLY
ARREST, INDICT XAVIER BECERRA
FOR BREAKING FEDERAL LAW.
>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKE MAYBE A
BIGGER DEAL THAN A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT IN
IS BEING SERVED BY THESE
POLICIES?
HARVARD HAS KIND OF AN AMAZING
NEW STUDY OUT ON ATTITUDES
TOWARDS IMMIGRATION AND IT SHOWS
THAT AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS ARE
85% OF BLACK VOTERS POLLED BY
HARBERT SAID YOU SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO COME TO THE
YOU.
WHY IS THIS NOT BETTER KNOWN,
THESE VIEWS?
>> IT'S NOT BETTER KNOWN BECAUSE
THERE'S A POLITICAL IMPERATIVE
THAT THIS KIND OF INFORMATION
HAS NOT GOTTEN OUT THERE.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT ALL THE
ADVERSE WAY BY ILLEGAL
PARTICULARLY BLACK MALES.
40%, 18-POINT DECLINE IN BLACK
APPOINTMENT LEVELS IS DUE TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
IF YOU DO THE MATH, WE ARE
TALKING OF OVER A MILLION PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE JOBS BECAUSE
IT GOES BEYOND SIMPLY THE
ECONOMIC ASPECT OF THIS, WHICH
IS DEVASTATING.
ISSUES.
TO TAKE CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE,
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET THIS
KIND OF DATA BECAUSE PUBLIC
OFFICIALS GUARD THIS DATA MORE
DATA OUT ON THE ILLEGAL
INFORMATION.
THERE'S AT LEAST TWO HOW
THOUSAND 430 ILLEGAL ALIENS DUE
TO MURDER.
A STUDY SHOWING ILLEGAL ALIENS
ESPECIALLY DACA-AGED ILLEGAL
ALIENS ARE 245% MORE LIKELY TO
COMMIT ALL MANNER OF CRIMES THAN
LAWFUL RESIDENTS.
THAT KIND OF STATISTICS WE HAVE
LOOKED AT, MY ASSISTANT AND I
BECOME A SPECIAL COUNSEL HAVE
LOOKED AT THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION AND HAVE SEEN THAT
ON AVERAGE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE STATES WHERE WE CAN FIND
THIS DATA, MEANING THE BIGGER
STATES LIKE NEW YORK, FLORIDA,
TEXAS, ARIZONA AND CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE LOOKING AT AT LEAST 60%
MORE LIKELY IF YOU ARE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT TO HAVE COMMITTED A
CRIME OF ANY NATURE, BUT MANY OF
RESIDENCE.
HORRIFIC IMPLICATIONS UPON THOSE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES, ONE OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES AS THE BLACK
WOULD HAVE A DEBATE ABOUT IT.
TRAVIS, ARE THESE FIGURES
DISCUSSED AT ALL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY YOUR MEDIA THERE?
>> UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE NOT.
ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
WHAT WE ARE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
IS ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT THE SANCTUARY
STATE.
THIS IS NOT EVEN PEOPLE THAT
HAVE COME HERE ILLEGALLY.
THIS IS PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME
HERE ILLEGALLY AND THEN COMMIT
CRIMES WHILE THEY ARE HERE AND
THEN THEY ARE BEING PAID FOR AND
IF THAT WASN'T ENOUGH, NOW
XAVIER BECERRA HAS THREATENED
EVERY CALIFORNIA BUSINESS OWNER,
AGAIN, IF YOU TRY TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW, IF YOU COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES DOING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTIES, HE IS
GOING TO PROSECUTE YOU UNDER
PROSECUTION, FIND $10,000 OR
CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: ITS GROTESQUE IF